Forge in Pennsylvania nearly 250 years
ago during a bitterly cold and wet
winter George Washington stationed the
Continental Army on this rural Plateau
just outside of Philadelphia now the
defensible position it gave Washington's
exhausted troops time to rest recover
recoup and retrain for what was the long
War ahead now tomorrow President Joe
Biden was set to give a big speech near
the very site in Valley Forge but not to
commemorate Washington or the heroes in
the Continental Army who won America's
fight for independence no instead Biden
planned to commemorate uh oh that's
right the capital Riot on January 6 2021
but due to possible snow in the forecast
the speech was moved up and took place
just a few hours ago now remember slick
conditions can be a fatal for a
president as frail and weak as Joe Biden
as I've been saying he is one fall away
and the Democrats may very well be
forced to pick a new nominee for 2024
now of course the content of today's
venomous speech remain the same to sum
it all up as I told you you're going to
hear this all election season long
according to Biden those who want to
make America great again you want to
America to be great again you are a
threat to democracy and only Joe Biden
who doesn't know what they is can save
us from ourselves take a look just one
day before January
6th a date forever shared in our memory
because it was on that day that we
nearly lost America lost it all today
we're here to answer the most important
of questions is democracy still
America's sacred
cause this is not rhetorical academic or
hypothetical where the democracy is
still America's sacred cause is the most
urgent question of our time and that's
what the 2024 election is all about the
choice is clear Donald Trump's campaign
is about him not America not you Donald
Trump's campaign is obsessed with the
past not the future because of Donald
Trump's
lies they died because these lies
brought a mob to
Washington he promised it would be wild
and it was he told the crowd to fight
like hell he forgot the words peacefully
patriotically March to the capital so
your voices will be heard how convenient
now also noticeably missing from those
remarks any mention of the economy or
inflation or national security or
violent crime or the fentanyl crisis now
in a blistering response former
president Trump told Fox News quote Joe
Biden is the worst president in the
history of the United States He is
incompetent he's crooked and in many
respects he is Benedict Arnold he is
destroying our country like no one else
has done before and meanwhile we've
heard the same device of speech from
Biden before and get ready and buckle up
as I said Tuesday my first show back for
the new year he will do this over and
over and over again throughout the 2024
campaign in fact it's one of the only
things Democrats are going to want to
talk about the lead up to the election
here is their plan watch for it notice
it observe it and you know Embrace this
you know what they're going to do they
will focus on Trump Trump trump January
6 January 6 January 6 by the way without
any context uh that should be relevant
without any mention of the 2020 riots
that they refer to as mostly peaceful
they will demagogue abortion and
whenever possible they will dust off the
usual Playbook that the Democratic party
has Republicans are racist sexist
misogynist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic transphobic uh the GOP
wants dirty air and dirty water and they
want some prominent Republican to push
your grandma and grandpa off a cliff now
in contrast here's what they won't talk
about and it's a long list they're not
going to talk about the failure of Joe
Biden's border crisis they're not going
to talk about the drug crisis they're
not going to talk about Joe Biden's
inflation they're not going to talk
about the horrible educational system uh
because of the democratic party's Unholy
alliance with teachers union they're not
going to talk about affordable housing
homelessness biomics they've been
talking about it for year yeah uh guess
what only 34% of Americans actually
think the economy is e even decent they
won't talk about Law and Order and
Safety and Security they don't want to
talk about International Affairs they
don't want to talk about the war in
Ukraine in Europe they don't want to
talk about the war in the Middle East in
Gaza they don't want to call terrorism
terrorism and the terror attacks against
our troops they don't want to talk about
the failure of their new green deal
socialism and get this even life
expectancy has gone down under Joe Biden
Joe Biden pretty much has failed at
everything are you better off than you
were four years ago so of course they
don't want to talk about accomplishments
because I can't think of any can you now
in fact you probably won't see or hear a
whole lot from Biden and the coming
months the media will Aid and ab bet him
hiding in the basement of the White
House once again and it appears that
he's headed back to that basement and
Joe is frankly he's not up to the rigors
of the job never mind a campaign now
here's Biden's recent schedule according
to the RNC research on December 22nd he
actually spent a few minutes at a
children's hospital in Washington DC
about 9 minutes anyway then he left for
vacation at Camp David he remained on
vacation until the the 26th and then the
very next day he left for another
vacation this one in the US Virgin
Islands and as evidenced by his horrific
sunburn well Biden baked in the
Caribbean heat for the next s days
during a relaxing stay in St Croy then
he returned to DC on the night of
January 2nd the next two days he
appeared to do absolutely positively
nothing that brings us to today's big
event a speech about how his political
opponents are evil in theory Biden has
two very difficult jobs one as
commanderin-chief and another on the
campaign Trail but it certainly appears
with anybody with eyes to see that Biden
is doing neither of those jobs and yet
he wants you the American people to
rubber stamp a second term hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else